welcome it's a pleasure to present the
first incarnation of our creative
fellowships of which Fanny how is the
first recipient I spoken before of a
vision for the poetry room as a space of
solitary meditation and a source of
solidarity and social life the creative
fellowships helped fulfill another
vision we've had for the room which is
to create a sight of synthesis not
unlike poetry itself recombinant
constantly reshaped and revised by those
who enter not merely an archive that
acts as a memorial to the past but a
space than an axe what Stanley Cavell
has called the task of unworthiness the
creative fellowships were established to
provide poets with funding and time to
generate new works of art from our
resources be those resources texts
recordings persons and in the hands of
Fanny how fellowship is not only what
generated the possibilities this year
but what was the form the work itself
took infinitely collaborative and full
of affinity her cinematic work embodies
not only the freedom of meeting and of
association which is one of the
fundaments of poetry but the freedom of
meeting herself again it's not
surprising perhaps in her final film
tonight be again which was originally
filmed in the early 90s and was
substantially revised this year
integrates excerpts from Dante who as
critic Susan Stewart has written
embodied the role of the poet as one who
actively revisits critiques challenges
and reintegrates his or her earlier work
and being and goes quote beyond mere
change as novelty to the exploration and
exhilaration of antithetical
possibilities for poet of this kind says
Stewart there is no end to the resources
in wait for him or her it is our hope
that this small fellowship has served to
revive this essential resource in Fanny
and that film will constitute a renewed
meeting place for her
in the years to come here to introduce
Fanny how more fully is the scholar
Keith Jones please join me in welcoming
down thank you all very much for coming
and thank you Christina for organizing
what I trust will be an extraordinary
evening dedicated to the films of Fanny
how we are here tonight to see and
discuss how and in what astonishing ways
families Fannie's turned to film extends
illuminates and crystallizes her poetics
her politics her attentions and beliefs
and the wondrous philosophical lucidity
of her thought while tonight is an
occasion to see three of family Fanny's
films new iterations of each
incidentally I do want to emphasize that
to think her filmic practice requires us
not to consider it as a departure from
her essays her novels or her poetry but
rather is further evidence of how fully
her genius lie in making genres overlap
and misbehave if we imagine genre as a
territory she is the trespass figure at
its margins without cramping your own
experience I will say a few words about
each film and the interest of providing
something of a context for considering
together and thinking through their many
marvelous instances their textures and
atmospheres their effects and their
charisma for those of us who are already
in all of the way her fiction and
nonfiction prose and poetry collapse and
tangle and fuse I trust you will find in
her films this evening that fabulous
transported of spell she casts over
words and images conveying us through
rich complicated worlds wherein paradox
is permitted but love and hope and
miss remain in tonight's opening film
Bridget of Marui a wonder tale shot in
2014 sound is the first thing like
breath
it begins with Gaelic a vadik
incantation we enter as if in an
underworld on a land bridge of ice a
mythic melting away to a taxonomy which
brings into being a teeming new world
which is Ireland
this is Fannie's and Sheila Gallagher's
inhabitation of st. Bridget's birth
there are rapturous blurring edgings add
mixtures of sound and voice it is a
total picture of the porousness of
life-forms all leaking light flaring up
scrawling their effects on water
affinities bloom as with the origins of
all things which are never singular
never punctual and never closed
we are the film tells us still in the
event of Bridget's birth there is a
wonderful keeping of time a beautiful
braid of past and present there's even a
stunning brew Sounion moment where the
cameras I dramatically dwells on mud
plashed hoods in a glorious crescendo
like moment the narrator will say there
were several Bridget's by the time she
was ten and ready to leave Meru we are
left to ask are there many mystics or
one a mysticism or many are all past and
futures
dream states of now the film is a
gorgeous proliferation of hope of
origins without end this is its wonder
and triumph the second film we will see
this evening what nobody saw originally
shot in 1987 begins with the baby
wailing for the thing the cameras eye is
confronted with a mother's breast it is
shot as if a wedge of moon the infant's
sustenance and basic tide of the earth
half an eclipse
indeed the film begins under the sign of
things
severed of relations and disrepair
we are in a fawn world a world of
dereliction the new cannot be added on
we are told but it is there it is there
in the rendering of its ruins as a
present overfilled and crumbling by the
weight of a future to come that has
already passed we have yet to recover
from or move beyond this improbable
baffling fold of time were past and
future temporalities touch is Fanny's
exquisite gift the film has an eerie
science-fiction feel in that Tarkovsky
sense of images cultures people's there
are once torn out of time and returned
to times that are strange to them as the
film's eye takes in the debris of its
world the narrator will ask is God a
help in that mercurial end of the day
light in all its symbolism where or what
the film asks is order is truth where or
in what lie our obligations to others
the final film we will see be again shot
in 1992 opens on Killiney Hill Dublin
with a strong deafening win and wood
pigeons COO the voice-over begins just
as a figure appears before us who we
assume is the voices embodiment an old
man on his proverbial three legs two
feet and a cane then the film for the
first time pauses in this film the
camera is in Fanny's hands and she is
following a figure with whom she will
never catch up we drift behind seeing
what she sees but only from a distance
and only from the outside even the
voice-over which typically permits
access to a character's inferiority will
not serve that function here there are
utter incision by any new mana within
the film's diegetic space the sky the
clouds the wind the cypress tree the
ocean the arbor for each seemed sealed
off one from the other
the narrator just another indwelling
presence among them
what we do know is that the film pauses
repeatedly by my count seven times
there's even this magnificent stutter
roughly three minutes in where the
camera doesn't seem to know quite what
to do
merely to linger or to fully pause and
it feels right early like we're watching
a sentence written over again but softly
there's thus this kindness and font and
fondness to these pauses for when the
camera rests it's as if we two are given
a moment to catch our breath to gather
ourselves and our thoughts and yet
they're never quite long enough indeed
we never fully catch up to the old man
who is always already ahead of us
vanishing into the very trail that is
the aura of his character Fanny has
quoted simone vey as having said the
beings i love our creatures they are
born by chance i want to think of these
films tonight as creatures born of
chance and i hope you too as i have
learned to love them please join me in
welcoming penny
Sheila and I have done everything
together that we're gonna present
tonight and behind draft of the the
first film brigitte of marui that we
sort of assembled and created together
so they demonstrate the uncertainty of
the beginning stages of work so tonight
the first film will show is the one that
he's spoken of called brigitte of maru
and after it will show the one with the
voice of Robert Creeley and that film
what nobody saw shows two grown up
people and a child but a lot of the
footage tonight has to do with children
in some sense
um and that film was made with john john
vedoe who's a wonderful filmmaker and he
told me about a year ago that I could do
whatever I wanted with it um but all I
did was try to change the soundtrack
because its film is so beautiful
and then Keith said the third will be
the little short film about that shows
my uncle
you know Ireland but Sheila now I would
sit in the cafe Algiers with her
computer and pens and paper preparing
for this film without knowing why we
were doing it we only knew that we were
supposed to show something at Glen stole
a be in Ireland last summer and that's a
ghost and Bridget what's in a lot of the
monastic Minds there so we didn't even
really care but Bridget the patron saint
of Ireland and so we have to say come up
with a reason to care and and that was
us and then behind that of course
there's always the great existential
question of why are we bothering to make
anything at all but usually a wish is a
secret thirst even to yourself then it
finds its corresponding weight in the
world they meet and give birth to an
idea that develops in darkness these
squalls on the screen are equivalent to
the little scratches a foetus might make
on the wall of the uterus let me out
sometimes the task is given and someone
calls and you have to seek out your
secret wish and match it up with the
needs of the caller Sheila is going to
actually give the story of the film's
literal magic and evolution but I wanted
to UM pursue a thought I keep trying to
get out of me something that keeps
fleeing and evading my speech or
articulation
and that's why do we do this scratching
it words in order to get to a beginning
or a bare space than some kind to return
to infancy to be without speech the
threshold between Eden and heaven
great ground and cloud hollowed out each
image will lose its definitions be
bit-by-bit a nymph in purgatory still
wears her headscarf or is it but
suddenly lying on the floor we tried to
domesticate our spirits like children we
chase and chastise them until they
change we spend our lives trying to
release them again then but into one I
see the loss of a certain spirit in us
as the loss of a child the fresh mind of
infancy in play it's the most interior
and submerged part of ourselves erased
and rewritten over the years what is
left is the longing for it to be able to
locate it with the words I recognize you
as if this submerged figure is still
watching us through the thickets of
experience through the physical body
that has covered it over and shed itself
by the seventh year cells like
inscriptions the child becomes a new
person between eight and twelve years
old years that are often hard for
grown-up people to remember that's
because the figure of this child is
empty as it is life is renamed
reconstituted sexualized and hardened
into a man or woman the archetype of the
divine child is usually an infant but
not always the divine child can continue
as a preteen an angelic boy or girl
pause before it's vanishing the child's
resistance is futile no matter how hard
it struggles to stop its horrifying
metamorphosis into a garland to this
child we pay homage with our deeds and
our choices and tasks because it remains
forever potential or it went another way
and never returned it haunts us not as
the fixed past but as something we gave
up too casually because there was no
other way
Bridget to me is an archetypal original
child this is what I decided she would
be that is a child who is androgynous
not finished but complete this child is
dissolved by fierce hormones and only
seems to survive them in the empty
spaces that run ahead and around us
neither male nor female indefinable
being our home Bridget otherwise known
as the paint patron saint of Ireland
began as a pagan goddess until she was
born on earth and here she made her home
in the great outdoors this is the way as
I say I've made her into something that
I can love this is one of the unique
facets of her long story she was a
goddess to the Druids then she was a
human and later became a thing she
multiplied through legends and through
her historical functions - that's Abbas
and artists in a way she shows us the
way gods were formed in the heavens
where they were what we now call the
weather and the passing clouds
Bridget may be the only woman who
spanned the abyss between sky and earth
with many stories of gods becoming
mortal or trees and flowers but none
with a long human history and legacy
she's associated with nature wells
smoke trees water honey green or whiskey
and fire she could work a forge and make
pots pants and air means she lived with
six virgins and slept with the same
woman every night of her life this is
the ground bridge and people Revere a
sensible monastic and generous fertility
figure more like Ceres than her daughter
Persephone
but it's the child Brigid who won my
heart more Persephone than series who
herself was a woman pursuing a child
the Brigid we won't see as an
unmanifested child who oversees invoices
over our failures to get to the open
field and fresh water to locate the
Silver Apples of the Moon the golden
apples of the Sun I've noticed that
reading aloud to a child puts the adult
in the role of an authority who is also
on the side of the child this
contradiction is so strong it might
explain why children fall asleep when
you read to them Sheila and I decided to
capture region of the realiable story on
film we went to the exact place on the
ground where I feel a child is still
playing Sheila is a magician with paint
plastic and color I would like her
therefore now to describe the strange
pursuit of Brigid
um first I just want to say thank you so
much it's a huge honor to be here
tonight with Fanny because it really is
her night and consequently I'm gonna try
to keep my remarks pretty short
collaborating with Fanny on our little
video Brigid of Meru I'm going to show
you has been full of magical
coincidences and little epiphanies and
also as you could see from the collage
of revisions and moving images a scab
that we sort of keep picking because we
can't get it quite right or maybe right
isn't the right word the the project for
me started in the summer of 2012 when I
visited the extraordinary Benedictine
monastery called Glenn stall in murrow
Ireland where Fanny has been sort of an
honorary poet monk in residence herself
for years and our mutual friend the
philosopher Richard Kearney had gone to
school and all of us share a very
special connection to an amazing person
there named named Patrick who's an abbot
and with whom we in different ways
communicate consciously and
unconsciously in words and dreams and
prayers he sees things in threes I'd
become interested in a strange figure of
Saint Brigid when I read that in the
fifth century she had not only
established a co-ed monastery in Kildare
which means the Church of the oak but
also the first art school which was
created to make illuminated manuscripts
at the same time in 2012 Fanny and I
were and I were both reading our friends
our friend Richard drafts of a novel in
which Brigid also appears as a kind of
hidden character whose spirits through
the story when I first started doing
research and found that Brigid was the
patron saint of poetry and healing and
art and also children who do not live
with their parents or are abused and
dairy farmers I recognised Fanny as one
of her incarnations Fanny is also
someone who like st. Brigid if she was
put ahead of a dairy farm would
no doubt have a white cow with red ears
and give all of the milk away to the
hungry the first summer at that
monastery film Fanny doing all sorts of
weird things miracles talking to donkeys
and putting her fingers in a lake to
melt the ice to free a fish had been
frozen underneath according to one
Bridgette a geographer and thinking I
was doing maybe doing a documentary I
also filmed an incredible monk Sean o
Dunn who himself is this childlike rigid
figure both a scholarly expert on the
rights of st. Brigid but also somebody
who slips seamlessly inhabits another
more innocent world of nature goddesses
that existed before churches I filmed
him for four hours and maybe I will show
you a little clip at the at the end and
after weeks of making pilgrimages to
Bridgette wells and gathering all this
footage I had tons and tons of video and
I sat on it for a year and I kept on
thinking that it was going to percolate
and and gel and it never did I had
images but no words and I really didn't
know what to do until enter Fanny and as
she said we'd have tea at Algiers we
talked about Bridgette and saints and
who the hell are they and what are they
and what what do you do with them and
who needs them and and she wrote dozens
of notes and versions and poems and and
really full-on essays and it seems like
she just wrote another one tonight as
well
and at one point after months of us
talking about all of this and being
completely engaged family announced
quite coldly that she was not at all
interested in Bridgette at all or Saints
at all and I was and I was completely
heartbroken
i I had no I had no story I had no
structure and then there was a little
miracle and I got this email from from
Fanny
um that says that she discovered that
shortly after her birth Bridgette was
sent away to foster care and miroux
to this tiny little charged sacred place
in the world where
install the monastery is located the
exact place where I filmed Fanny was the
same place where the child Brigid had
played this was the coincidence that
allowed Fanny to re-enter the project
again and this time looking for the
child and I realize now that this sort
of negative theology a hard turning away
that can enable a return to a different
permutation is a key part of the
hundreds of indecisions visions and
revisions that marks the creative and
collaborative process at least with us
the next summer in Glen Stahl came the
second sign we were again at Glen stall
and Fanny took a walk in the woods near
the monastery one of the last surviving
primeval
oak forests in Europe where Brigid must
have walked and there she found a KitKat
wrapper definitive proof of the child's
Saints I finished this little the first
little video of sorts with Fanny's words
and my images in the fall of 2013 and I
showed it in the bathroom of the Dodge
Gallery in New York we called it a work
in progress and it was not for sale we
both felt it was too pious too pretty
too definitive and it was really only
saved by the line I think that the
shithole is the site of a mess made holy
and which inspired me I think at Fanny's
and encouragement to put a pile of
manure that my mother gathered in New
Jersey and surrounded it by marigolds on
the bathroom floor the there is the
there's Fanny the third little miracle
came last summer we went back to Glen
stall for a solstice gathering about
something about Bridget and I carved a
piece of oak a cross-section of oak from
Boston with some of Fanny's distilled
lines and I flew it with me to Ireland
and we took it out into the three
thousand-year-old Bridget woods and we
projected images on the wood and
whiskey and eight Kit Kats with father
Anthony a druid priest who knows
everything about trees and then
underneath the images seem to
miraculously appear a female figure and
so Bridget who intrigues and inspires
because for me she really is this site
of endless projections and possibilities
for transmutation and revisions was
there she was there in the woods and is
still there trying to emerge out of the
dark wood there's a few little images
that st. Bridget's cross
this was just a flash of light that made
its way into st. Brigid that's an image
of st. Brigid
and finally wanyan a kind of a Buddhist
Chinese representation of Brigitte so
now finally I'm going to show you the
second Brigitte video which we made to
be shown at the monastery last year with
my images and Fannie's words and also
the voice of her granddaughter
romka hall
phone
Canoga do
Colin come on color religion car dread
Allah free long
fear
for sure
not long before this story began the
Irish Sea was a freshwater lake and the
first humans crossed a land bridge that
was only a thin bar of ice from Britain
the Sun raced over the icy hills of
Ireland and out of the melting water
came maidenhair fern sand wort eyebright
fleabane orchid saxifrage st. patrick's
cabbage blue-eyed grass a single
strawberry tree and salmon with all of
their names there were gods and
goddesses fading away with the ice and
into the lakes and the animals who
became them there were shepherds and
slaves to take care of the cows and
lambs many of the slaves were children
into all this a baby was born as a slave
to her father
her mother was a slave too he sent far
away when her child was born the baby
Bridget vomited when her druid father
touched her he promptly sent her off to
Meru a lovely part of Limerick to live
with the Ryan clan it was in Meru that
bridge had resisted every form of
bullying and bondage so her foster
family let her run freely
off to the oakwoods she went there she
began her studies she learned to read
from the shapes of twigs and stones and
rushing water lily pads and fish she
traced a map of the woods of Meru on the
shell of a turtle she smeared eyes on
her finger from Lewton bluebells
and violet then wet them with a drop of
Dew inch loops and circles she saw eyes
in everything and eternity in the lives
of bees and songbirds the black birds
sang
ecstatic melodies in the evening her
chosen time she felt she was always
being observed in accompanied when it
was frosty the day was pinched and dark
like the shadows inside a cloak she made
herself a cloak out of spiderwebs or was
it frost it could stretch all the way to
the moon
she was a girl in headscarf who lived
like an animal in the safety of night
and shadow she followed the workhorse
that carried the milk pails to the bully
with her hand on his foreleg tribes
inhabited the woodlands where she roamed
and she fled every male one of them
coming through the trees this frigid
lived in the fifth century when people
were writing poetry and screams she had
her special cave up a rocky hill
overlooking a scummy River there she hid
her first dwelling was made of potatoes
that brought it in the rain her second
was made of turf and manure but these
two sink with damp into stink holes she
promised herself she would build a solid
house of stone when she had again of
girls like herself to join her in the
building
this was still the childhood of the
world Persephone and the nymphs and the
yellow meadow had barely left our sphere
of time while Brigid was in the forest a
few months and druids were writing poems
and songs she had only herself out of
which to create a dozen thoughts out of
Maru and in a dark cave she knocked out
syllables one by one according to the
new measures of time air was magic
whipping people away over the sea and
land never to be seen again
Brendan sets sail on his raft and pollen
pill wept leaving Ireland and
disappeared
there were several Bridget's by the time
she was ten and ready to leave Maru they
multiplied through the shafts of air one
going one way another going another here
and there around the countryside all the
Bridget's were able to break through
barriers of light and night to be in
many towns at once one put her finger in
water and it became a well one began as
a rivulet been turned into an island
shaped like a rabbit one bridge and like
Francis a thousand years later formed a
model for the church today with men and
women separate but equal in their lives
devoted to poverty community quiet and
something else without a name the child
Brigid of Meru lived off alone and slept
on hay at night she liked men called
Patrick when they were monks and
shepherds but basically she was an
original an invisible girl she still
haunts a little grove of trees in Meru
but only children knoweth I will tell
you soon why I care about her story when
once I have understood how it follows
from all the work I've done over the
years and not before
but that was supposed to be horrible so
the next one will be 10 minutes plus 30
sentence tonight we may not have time to
do the little Irish one of mine but I'll
try to speed through this this is the
one that I made with John john vedoe in
1987 it was fun I had this idea about
breaking into a place that was then had
been when I was a child called Mattapan
estate hospital and it was abandoned and
lay rotting on the road to Mattapan and
I always used to be terrified of it but
but so that's why I won't have to get
inside and film it because of my
childhood fear of it and so we did and
we broke in through windows to may of
John and another film person and then
three actors a man a woman in there
child and after it was done I sent my
script up to Robert Creeley in Buffalo
and asked if he would read from it and
he immediately did and then my friends
also did a voiceover but I've been
tormented for years of not liking the
voice-over at all so it was when John
said you can do whatever you want like
excited to to go back and change the
sound to just be really speaking
he's got such a lonely voice it's always
lonely his poetry and it fits so well
with with this horror story which is
actually a kind of I also had in my mind
the Persephone story even then all of
them looking for each other a true
revolution is always beginning to I'm
swimming in a density of chemicals and
meanings so web within my Anatomy I
can't even know whether my questions are
part of the machine or floating over it
April 24 33 years later what do you see
from there all my decisions have been
wrong it looks like mosquitoes and
purple snakes are died into his
polyester shirt it's incumbent on us to
seek the good in others God being
unlimited encompasses within itself the
whole perfection of existence and won't
stretch for something new to be added on
interminable it's we've tied Kota
similar perfect the possessive is God
help
she will go wild and call it old like
barbecued ribs and jazz she will grow
red tragic the American experiment works
without history that's why it fails
October 15th 46 years later I see bar
when did I transgress my own shadow
when did mine change and I did shame is
a chemical in the air here May 13th
Joan of Arc was burned at the stake
learn your history since you can't
remember
April 24th 33 years later I wonder what
she sees
her nipples pointed west through her
Jersey when we went to the Justice of
the Peace penetrate or participate I ran
away
choosing personally to spend my life
alone I now prefer the indifferent and
meaningless things in the world all the
rest
our wife's belly button this is curly
and close to the divine from the hills
smoke from old kochu it fires still
makes me wonder where God wants me to be
in why anyway
she giggled through her cheeks she said
satisfaction guaranteed again and again
ideology even nobody made something six
months before I can't see much if you
called God the truth wouldn't you feel
better
the person comes to nothing if you don't
believe it talk to a surviving everyone
who didn't die yet is dying
radiant is the head Sun I've been why do
young people deny the possibility that
any one of them might be a saint or a
hero
you
it's the man in the film is my uncle
John Manning who was an electrical
engineer and a camera person for short
experimental films made in Dublin in the
1930s he was someone who never left
Ireland he just he loved loved being
there and trying to make friend of his
was Samuel Beckett whom he revered and
remembered from their welcome together
on Killiney
Hill in Dublin which is where this is
shot and he that I drew the text out of
Dante's purgatory which
imagine of renovated as justice rule and
innocence and the human race capable of
sustaining enter into a new life knowing
that you cannot go back to the homeland
you can't even want to go back or you
will have to retreat
some people walk slowly as from a
terrible one that they yearn to be free
of by walking still we are all citizens
of the same city we may have no one road
assigned to us on earth or out of
purgatory but we are allowed to find a
way whatever it is to this city some
people in well at the light a little
pebbles they are fixed but rest as if
questing for a bigger fire
when it's unsettled carried it through
the song is in Jerusalem if you're
wondering how the world can go to such a
sorry state exam are you came to be orgy
expressing happiness make birds happy
there is an ambience around each person
created by the content of that person's
character everybody needs a teacher or
as he or she stands utterly alone
you
so fahnny I remember the other version
of the Matapan fan and I wonder if you
would consider putting your voice back
in okay they have answers there clearly
his voice there was an understated
tribal a soundtrack and it was very
mesmerizing what was that and it wasn't
credited at the end of the movie - well
maybe our salmon I put his name there
cuz he put it on recently when I cut out
the other voices and just left freely I
said please put in some kind of a
soundtrack
oh that is yeah - it Thanks yeah
I'm drinking whiskey it was wonderful
I'd like to talk to you more about
Ireland I've worked with Irish weed
woman for instance one named terrazzo
Mahoney is very important in in the West
Cork area but I was wondering saying all
that and how wonderful it was I have a
little bit of a critique I would love to
have the Blackbird toned down about 80
percent in the last film as it more
subliminal presence I don't know what
you think about that it sort of
dominates over the voice I don't think
about that for sure
hi thank you so much for showing these
phones um they were mesmerizing I'm
wondering about the difference in your
process of editing especially between
the first and the second one because the
first one is quite literally illustrates
the text or even when the the image is
at times transcendent because of itself
like the moon that has four iterations
and stretching of the moon but generally
it's very one-to-one text an image and
in the second one I didn't see that at
all and it transported me in a
completely different way and allowed all
kinds of kind of juxtapositions and and
concepts to merge because I was trying
to think between the image and text so
I'm wondering especially I'd love to
have you both talk about the editing
process Thanks it was you know like a
children's story that I was reading
aloud so it was more illustrative in
that sense but you did they're all meant
that you free yeah we actually tried to
not have because a lot of the images
came even before the the words but then
they found found their mates in the in
in the words and but that was one of the
hardest things is not to have either the
words illustrate the images or the MS
images illustrate the words but I think
we were working so closely together and
we're so sort of sensitive to but the
other person's idea was and
we could fuse fuse those two a third
thing that it did and being more
illustrative and but as Fanny said also
I mean sort of keeping the child's
interest it's at the tempo of but
there's that it's an image to a word and
I'm flipping a book almost the other
free-floating voice is something that
was doing in fiction for years was
inserting some poetic statements or
thoughts from a non-existent person
where else it could be thought of as a
consciousness that they were but
everybody is sharing but only one is
expressing that you thought that because
I thought it looks a lot of them are
sort of off that the the spider eating
its young was the equivalent of the
druid Prince you know raping his
daughter right no but that's what we
have this spider yeah yeah there was
actually a much darker version of this
the first one we did was way too light
the one that was in the bathroom and
then Fanny rewrote a text that was
incredibly dark and full of of rapes and
famine
but then she wanted her granddaughter to
read part of the text and so that it got
way cleaned up in the final famous Megan
the what nobody saw not only did his
voice sound kind of lonely but he also
had a certain rhythm that fit synced up
perfectly with the movie so was he
watching the movie as he read that
already to do a blind you never saw them
that's amazing never he just literally
so generously sat down and recorded it
with his home
all right send me the tape and then I
cut and pasted the things around was
beautiful yeah what was the bit that you
meant to cut from the end of the first
film because oh but I thought that was a
lovely line what was the line again all
this oh no I thought it was a great lens
I'll tell you about it someday when I
finished all my work I thought was oh oh
no keep that
okay